on verra alors que la situation
sanitaire semble se dégrader on l'a vu
en france et ailleurs en europe
quelle est la situation en russie
bonjour grenouille nouveau jour nouveau
record 15 mille 150 cas confirmé du côté
de 19 ce vendredi en russie au kremlin
on se dit préoccupé par la dynamique des
chiffres mais assure que tout est sous
contrôle
le kremlin est effectivement préoccupé
par ces données statistiques on voit que
l'épidémie se propage à très grande
échelle
voilà pourquoi des mesures énergétiques
sont prises afin d'encourager tout le
monde a respecté les strictes mesures de
précaution qu'on a il faut l'admettre
ignorer assez longtemps c'est la
première chose
la deuxième chose est que la situation
actuellement est effectivement sous
contrôle même si cette dynamique est
déplorable le temps le ministre de la
santé michael moore âge qu'un annoncé la
fin de la première phase des essais
cliniques pour le troisième vaccin russe
c'est le centre de recherche et de
développement de médicaments où on
oublie logique tu markov de l'académie
russe des sciences qui s'est chargé de
la création du nouveau remède contre le
coronavirus la deuxième phase des essais
cliniques doit être accompli en décembre
ce qui ouvrira le chemin pour
l'enregistrement du vaccin en russie je
rappelle qu'il s'agit du troisième
vaccin aux russes contre le coronavirus
après spoutnik les mises au point par le
centre de recherche moscovite dans
mahler enregistré le 11 août
le deuxième vaccin les caves à corona
conçu par le centre de recherche et des
acteurs de novosibirsk a été enregistré
par les autorités du pays le 14 octobre
à merci verhaeghe hoffman en direct de
moscou en russie dont